[Music]
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
so I seems to be done this with the
daddy himself well so you got an
announcement to make
yeah for those who aren't aware of it
but but first right hold that thought
because we have these messages from our
sponsors
brave genuinely new yet
go do your lab raiding Jill have
shadowing Jill of Legends horse you do
you're right here did you a legendary
shuttle Raider good see that's brilliant
he loves dark fantasy this is not a PG
about that he loves to play it that's
the game where is it available I'll tell
you what it's not a viola right you
can't just imagine here no yeah use your
imagination isn't that good you just
involved a little bit of downloading er
the internet yeah and of course you do
on your phone good and on PC as well so
as the shocker
that is amazing it was just got the
stick everywhere exactly that's the good
thing it's got this PC level of graphics
on a phone if there's anything I can
play with in my hand or was a good thing
the gameplay is getting better and
better each time as well let me show you
some of my champions look at this one
the female version of Gallic giornata
Israel's shaman that's my idea of
happened have you ever seen Vikings she
looks like the girl out of Vikings yeah
yeah you know I love about this one as
well this one here sniper will put a
belly on sure that ya know but not only
that I mean I do worry about that
because she's left herself exposed I
always worry about that but the good
thing is shielding from covert so so
she's observing yeah I like that they're
culturally aware and as is this guy if
anyone's got PPE is this the horns you
know what I mean or the hell yeah it's
making a statement as yeah and now if
that guy was Prime Minister I'd go with
him enemies sure Brian yeah happy with
you champions and they're amazing
but what about my shards show me your
shards laws I want to show you my shards
the shards um from all over the game you
sort of earned them as you go around on
your missions and they earn you like
little rewards as you go along this is a
mystery shard ah he's alright peace
mazzani's beauty look at that let's open
this one now look at that powerful woman
but you
she's a right sassy boss CC you get a
pretty good reward for that from that
one was I think we should all just get
what shards oh if there's one thing I
want you all to do it's to get your
shards
show me your shot show me your shards
wonder something in game tournament so
I'm going I've already been an order
yeah well let me tell you I really need
you maybe these guys at home on as the
spiders then ice columns peak the
almighty fire night very like you and
the notorious dragon that one's me
Chinese New Year you tiger tiger dragon
so cool we are tiger and dragon so he
likes the green woman and I like the
green man maybe they could have you ever
seen that the sort of mirror we could be
I'm not sure if that's how I would do it
yeah if I was gonna piss but if I was
gonna pick anyone to do that with it
would be well when I did watch black
mirror I don't think we make sure you're
quick with our link in the description
because every new player will get an
exclusive welcome pack all you want to
get in there yeah super quick
what for buying a hundred thousand
silver that's right and you get to clown
boskie's and ten mysteries shots nailed
it and a free awesome champion
adjudicator
she's a saucy little minx isn't sure
typically you'll find your extra rewards
here in your inbox for the next 30 days
you can find me under the nickname loss
curse so see us on where our legends we
hope to see you there as well alright
welcome back from that we look different
yeah because a lot has happened since
you bid that little advert with me it
was a great ad to be fair I was pretty
chipper I think when I read that I was
like hey let's just chill least another
two or three weeks until yeah you know
the big day and then then with this sort
saw so going but in time sure people
know what we're talking about
I suppose the thumbnail in the title yes
Blaine Lazarus as our dad yeah Wow he's
a miner
yeah it does we can get into that later
yeah yeah fully yeah so going all the
way back to the night of conception how
good was it
ejaculated the feel great Jackie I it
wouldn't be right if I didn't just
really know
I don't think you have her in there I
mean because if you didn't know right
what happens is mod when a man loves a
woman pops it in the in a you know in a
very specific place a very loving area
of the body dunno that's really funny
I'm gonna have to have this chat with
him I got loads I had a little bit of a
lot or so up until no don't say that
that makes me sound terrible yeah no but
like we was having a good time and then
everyone had a good time and it loads us
all about a good time yeah and so I
never for all of you lot and I've been
keeping this secret the whole time so if
you're wondering yes I can't keep a
secret and G own you as well
yeah and roving well yeah yeah alright
that it's about me no but I'm saying you
tell you it's about me Lawrence this is
podcasters about me of the people that
knew you probably knew first [__]
hope so
yeah yeah you knew first even beyond the
doctor I think yeah is there yeah I just
say it's a bit of a surreal experience
to my left the house for a few days and
you know left
so I've got a media question yeah you
know when you leave the house no yeah do
you feel different do you feel like oh
god what if something cut are you a bit
panicked a bit worried no I don't worry
because I know he's capable of looking
after himself very much you know
self-soothing bob is not a really hope
the orgies are the podcast funds are
like what yeah yeah because this to me
I'm doing this for them the ones who
witnessed us call from you know kids in
a bomb shelter - you know businessman
amazed yeah I mean and you know what I
am I'll say this I don't care about
other people's kids and I and I hate
hearing about other people's kids so
I've been very conscious of just boring
other people with news of children no
but this is the thing you said you've
suddenly bought [__] godless twenty
pictures nothing like people I'm sorry
if I'm boring yard yeah I'm coming I
love it
I've got loads and loads of Roton and
also you obviously you know I'm not
showing his face publicly either backing
show his feet and you know the back of
his head and stuff yeah I think most
most comments on that on the pictures
and tweets have been fairly respectful
I've seen the odd [__]
I don't care about this because when
you're when you become a new father you
don't really mind about that do you
I think there's a line and it's
important to each to their own of what
their line is and it's to stick with
that you know what I mean but what made
me think when I was thinking how can you
make the podcast interesting obviously I
can tell you the story of Earth if you
want to hear that I mean yeah I've been
we've deliberately not talked about this
yet right and then also my whole life I
wanted to be a dad right my whole life
and I always thought oh you'll be a dad
one day and that's good and then you
know even no matter how prepared you
feel no matter how old you are no matter
what point it comes you'll always feel
an element of being unprepared and will
not be ready for the experience a bit
like an exam or any of these sorts of
things and I thought you know there's a
lot of people watch this and they'll be
bored about just hearing about just kids
mm-hm when it finally happens they just
like wow this is the most natural easy
thing in the world and you just go not
easy but it has probably felt kind of
easy but you just go oh yeah of course
no but that's for you this is the thing
from the day I met you
yeah you've changed me for the better
and in your Joran yeah but you're a
natural how do I put this I want to say
like helping hand like you you you are
good at guiding you can yes what why I
am Who I am and I'm not that will never
change yeah yeah you've definitely
helped me a lot along the way so that
when you used to talk about wanting to
be a dad yada yada yada and and then
when you said you were going to be a dad
there was never a second where I thought
Lawrence isn't ready for this yeah
believe me there's been many a friend of
mine who I thought what the [__] yeah
with you I never had a second to worry
about it because it was like he's gonna
be fine
so you kind of born for this and there's
there's no there's no work don't get me
wrong I'm sure you'll have your moments
and that's just normal I look tired I
mean you've always look tired
lockdown hasn't changed you in it's not
it changed my life but it hasn't changed
my look I've always looked tired I've
always had shaggy hair this is ideal can
I just say I'm totally a mess right now
because we're so excited for ya and also
true Geordie much is available soon if
your wondrous tonight
range some of the people are like yeah
we've won that then what the web sites
come and don't worry that give us a
couple of weeks it'll be up
it looks amazing actually yeah that is a
great t-shirt the hoodie is really nice
hoodie is nicely appointed feels really
nice on some people have cheap merch
some people I've seen some merch
recently cut for Ezio's good much I'll
give him that
but other people [__] no lots of thing
I don't want to make this about the most
I just remember that we did we were
supposed to promote right before we get
into the good stuff good merch coming to
it and I have waited four or five years
to do this so it's it's we're not gonna
take the piss with you guys we're gonna
give us some it nice and a decent price
do you want to take it to the morning
off maybe we start the night before the
mobile story goes back while all that we
just watched Liverpool draw against
Everton well I had no one else on the
show was really watching we're all just
sort of chatting away and horrible goo
yeah but we were all very relaxed
everyone was quite chilled and obviously
after the show everyone just sort of
stands around and chats and everyone's
going oh you know how you feel in things
going well people are giving up bits of
advice and sort of you know I'm Rory
Rory goes and this is a point where I
knew that the baby would not come on
time because Rory goes mate they are
always on time or late for the first one
and I instantly thought babies early
though and that is that is Rory as a
curse Rory's Rory is just Rory says
something in you it won't happen
basically the men one of the main things
that Rory once said on a game will be
watched on the kickoff as he goes
dubbing Louise had never misses a penny
he's just about a step well you're very
miss he'll bury this miles white yes up
I actually said you that night yeah this
is your last father's do you'll ever
have without actually having right baby
and and it turned out be the last day
yeah yes I now get a text message first
thing in the morning which I really
appreciate by the way going she's gone
into labor
yeah the thing I know you I know you so
alright so I message you back and I'm
like I'm very calm right now I'm on
reply so I'm good just everything's
gonna be fine remember everything
they've told you you know listen to the
nurses just got out of the hospital and
they're gonna walk you through it you're
not gonna have to worry about anything
and you just replied oh yeah yes yes yes
yeah I was like nervous but I'm sure you
were worried but at the time I thought
he's [__] you instantly went if you
do need a shot on the phone let me know
and at that point well I'll get to that
point we can go back to that and then I
got back I was quite tired and then we
got we got into bed together and I was
like you know you're I you comfortable
she wasn't really great so this is over
for so yeah because he's quite a he was
he was beginning to feel like quite big
as a baby I'm probably probably at about
five months in the pregnancy and we were
like yeah he looks about ready to come
now cuz flus quite petite and quite
small she's not you know people don't
realize you are a six foot one at least
something for two so he's gonna be a
taller guy the chance is hurting me yeah
right
and and he was in this where every time
we go to the Midwife that she would be
like ah he's quite tall he's quite long
but he's not very [__] can I just
stop you because I'm gonna do this
unlocks I'm so excite right so the first
time you ever seen them on screen yeah
just describe that moment it's really
surreal because you look at your own as
a father you're looking at your own face
or you're looking at something that you
look at it and it's like looking in a
mirror but and you can recognize
features and you like kind of looks like
me and that is me and did it make you
feel a bit different about the whole
thing when you recognized yourself there
in like an arrogant way but I already
had become attached to him and I was
already like you are that but you begin
to think kind of confirmation at that
point yeah and it changes your approach
because you begin to go okay and you
begin to make your mind subconsciously
starts making links and you're not
consciously going through it but you're
you start changing the way you're at
changing the way you think and that sort
of stuff
and suddenly you're just like oh yeah
right yeah and your heart skips and it's
just a completely different feeling from
there on you've been calmer since that
right open you know a lot obviously I've
talked about that way back then lockdown
helped and I get what you're saying and
then I've just read a lot since like you
know the night before he was born I read
for some reason I felt as real urge to
read pages and pages of Kobe Bryant's
book and was just like it's this really
empowering like affirmative you've got
this like all these things now is like I
don't know why but I really need to read
this book write a proper man doesn't it
and he's a man with many kids yeah and I
read it and I was like okay close the
book go to sleep don't know why I need
this right now but I totally need to
read this and I read it and it's a great
is so there's so many little bits in
there from someone who read did a lot at
about 3:30 in the morning flew gets out
of bed but I was used to it at this
point because obviously when you're
pregnant you get up a lot but I'd always
wake up and be like do you need anything
Jones can I get a drink or something
and she always say no and then at about
five o'clock in the morning it just she
just goes yeah I think is happening and
I was like I thought now when I was a
kid we used to fly on holiday and my mum
used to tell me that I would wake up
like they woke me up in the middle of
the night ready to go to the airport and
I'd always wake up and go yep good let's
go and like be so ready and that's
exactly this was recently it's taken me
a bit of time to wake up lock down this
welcome so I was like yeah okay cool
cool let's go flus having contractions
but she's like it might not be the real
thing about ten minutes apart about nine
minutes apart that's really it from what
the hospital tell you that's hours away
from it so we were both quite chill but
the sun's really risen and you know our
apartment there's this panorama have you
follow Lord sanam scroll you've stood a
lot of the view must be sick fish ship
so there's this panorama of London and I
looked outside and flew went into the
living room and just for a second my
knees went weak and I was just like [__]
and I just sat down and just went this
is not time to do that like this is not
the time for you to go I'm let's think
about me for a second I was like this
isn't about you so I was like right get
your [__] together do what you do when
you're gonna do the things you will need
color of some guts right exactly and
there's another moment in the birth
where that happens and I was like okay
get up so go in we start timing the
contractions and they start slowing down
and flu is like see I told you it's not
really happening but sorry to wake you
up and then suddenly
they've become very very fast and all
these instructions that we've been
reading through are like okay when it
says five minutes we call them there's
like nine ten minutes and then suddenly
it went four minutes and I'm sitting
there timing them going you know four
minutes apart do I tell you that these
are four minutes apart or not and then I
just I just went I think we should call
the hospital and just check and we call
them and the woman's like hmm yeah yes
maybe you should head in and I was like
oh okay
so we we go get in the car
begin tear down and flew at this point
and a vast references is like beginning
to get quite pained by the contraction
because anyone who's witnessed the birth
knows early on they're testing and then
after a while they just suddenly become
very uncomfortable - p.m. yeah and
they're beginning to get quite painful
at this point in the back of this tree
making a lot of noises both in the car
she's not as much as I thought and I was
a bit like as much as a sewer okay this
is impressive you dealing with this
really well mmm I get to the hospital
and they stop her and then they stopped
me and they go you need to wait down
here she's gonna go upstairs and I was
like what am i doing I'm carrying the
bags and stuff so I stand there waiting
for the bags and they send her up and
they go they'll assess her and then
maybe in an hour they'll come down and
what am I gonna be standing here for a
[__] hour so I'm standing there this
is all I wish but I was also like why
can't I just come up now like we know
it's happening so five minutes past and
then this little woman runs up to me
it's like you need to go upstairs right
now and I was like okay so I'll get all
the bags rock upstairs and there's you
know in hospitals you go corridor
corridor corridor so I'm going around
all these corridors and I'm like looking
for the birthing and everyone's going
yes that way and I get to the place and
I go hey I'm here for and they go oh
yeah follow me I'm pulling the bags and
stuff because we got his clothes her
clothes my stuff that I you know camera
bag and I walk into the room and flues
looking the other way and the woman just
goes yeah so a five centimeters dilated
will be ready to give birth in the next
hour
and I was like sorry what and but I was
thinking we'll be here for nine ten
hours it's like we can chill for people
if it is spoke and we wanted a pool for
the birth I know they're by the way I
know that young men don't give a [__]
about birthing stories around cuz it
might be handy for you one day you're
definitely gonna get someone pregnant
even if you're gay see what I mean yeah
yeah yeah you're fired to put that the
burden exactly Lord yeah exactly yeah
well I mean you know Dale Winton Phillip
Schofield I'm not like him at that point
was there a bit of panic
was there no no it was the opposite it
was almost like the Midwife or so in
control and so like positive about it
because she was like yeah she lets you
Trent the baby I'll be here in an hour
and we were like cool Trent and then
I'll clock off and go home and we were
like what kid you got an early flier
yeah I think she was sort of happy she
was a bit like yeah can pop this one out
before her head off and that'll be
they'll do the quota for the month and I
so I put the bags down and flues on the
bed facing forward and just facing me
and she was like don't go down the other
end and I was like oh I should just I'm
not asking for any other reason other
than trying to picture what's going on
in your sure you were know the last
thing I've had to try there was a woman
giving birth man out there you perfect
some of them are love it
Oh Utah she's facing forward like it so
she's not on her back just you know news
looking at basically yeah sorry flu and
so it's natural in it yes it's so
natural when in that moment
I'll admit like as a man I was in awe of
her I was looking at her I was like wow
you know this is amazing yeah and a few
days before I'd listened to a podcast
with Emma Thompson you know the wife
from Love Actually yeah yeah and he's a
great actress isn't she great actress I
don't know why I pick Love Actually but
that's the only film that I imagined she
was a I think she was in the Donna why
we're going down this road but there's
something for a minute what some sushi
they did they did the true story about
who's the woman who used to miss Mary
Poppins Mary pop yes oh the one who
brought Mary Poppins she played that in
the new Disney remote yeah she's really
good yeah she's a great actress who's
also in the name of the Father sorry all
right I've just spoken or we can go down
IMDB later expect a full Emma podcast
Emma Thompson public
she would be amazing she is a great
storyteller as I saw from Desert Island
Discs it was an old one and I'd listen
to it weirdly out of the blue because it
was something that I really thought was
so she said in Desert Island Discs she
she talked about giving birth and she
described it in the most beautiful way
and I remember when I first went to
university I listened to this is like a
ten-year-old podcast and I first went to
university and I was like oh that
changes they like she was like it's
empowering you lean your head back and
you raw and suddenly you've got a baby
and I was like yeah that's what flu
looks like she looks like it's really
powerful I just got down on my knees to
be like face to face with her and was
just like I just looked in the items
like you got it she was strong you'll be
all right
and she was on gas now and she was like
yeah cool and I was just like yep okay
the gas now is incredible right I didn't
have it but the effect it has is pretty
insane what do you mean what what what
was the doing world you think it shoots
breathing it very heavily and I think it
was just really like chilling around and
it wasn't definitely making her eyes
cross that's all I remember
and so I was just like this is good okay
you're clearly not you're clearly a bit
in the room and then not too much
although you're in agony correct yeah
that's what you want she didn't have
anything else but that didn't have an
epidural it was really natural birth but
she kept saying when are we gonna go to
the pool and the midwives kept looking
at me and being like and she was I and
even the Midwife is a bit like hmm I
don't know can we fill it up in time and
I was like sorry least [__] try
please not coming up this baby oh cool
yeah she said and then in walks a
midwife with a Scouse accent and I was
like oh really and at home and she
sounded just like some my family and
she's got she's you know she's cooking
in there so she was lovely and she was
making jokes and she was so I thought
you loved that yeah scoffs Midwife is
delivering your anymore and flu is like
flu turned around she was like oh you're
going from my for my last appointment
and they'd had this appointment and
they'd had a good appointment so she was
like oh great you're here and then
another Midwife walks in and cuz no one
else has given birth on the ward we've
got like four or five Midwife just
popping in and out
you guys good you want to teach on
anything everyone was so chill and was
there any worries about the covered
thing was what people were in like all
wearing masks but they turned to me and
they were like you can take your mask
off if you want and I was like okay cool
so we're not wearing masks but everyone
else is and everything was cleaned like
super it smelt clean it was all very
clean and they were doing a really good
job and you look on the bed down the
other end you know not not at the you
know but you look at the instruments now
I was like [__] are we gonna need any of
those yeah there's like these scissors
and this plunger thing I guess should
just stick in and just and you know the
things that you cut the umbilical I've
watched one Lord every minute and it was
it was horrendous yeah I love you I'll
be honest this was nothing like if you
imagine that that's what I was imagining
nothing like that there's a lot of
screaming that sure yeah a lot of
screaming this was a lot less screaming
and a lot more just sort of going and a
lot more just like it felt so natural to
her and she was just going she was
breathing she was she'd studied hypno
birth so she was sort of hypnotizing
herself and calming herself and we were
sort of doing things together and we
were looking each other in the eye
pretty much the whole time and I'm not
like was not a little bit like when she
when her eyes went crossed we were
looking each other in who'd know but
like it was very linking you were very
like that
that's a heavily bonding moment without
without you know even just a stare into
someone's eyes for a long period of time
it's hard not to feel something and then
of you combined up the thought that
she's given birth to your baby or you
know both of your baby yeah you know
what I'm saying like for a man for a man
that's some powerful [__] yeah so we
were very close and she and every and
this is what we were told by the Midwife
is every birth you get to a point where
you don't think you can do it anymore
mm-hm and I've told you about my PE
teacher on the podcast before who said
to me like the point we don't think you
need it anymore that's when you're just
about to do it I'm flu turned to me she
went I can do this I'm too tired and I
was like your body is just relaxing so
you can just slip this baby out you will
be absolutely fine
flip the little poppy oh yeah and at
that point they put the heart monitor on
the side so they sort of every now and
again after a contraction they put the
heart monitor on the side on the side of
of sort of on her belly but bit lower
and they for ages they've been like yeah
he's called not worried and then they
were like he's getting a little bit
distressed now because clearly he'd been
like he just wanted to come out you've
been pushing up on him and then flew
just light looks up and he's just like
right and just starts like going for it
and and I and what I noticed was and I
wasn't consciousness but what every time
she was pushing my I was sensing my
whole body and I looked at my hand when
she was like doing the final pushes I'm
out knuckles were like white because we
were holding hands so tight and earlier
on in the birth I was like don't know if
we should hold hands anymore cuz she had
gone ha and so I biting this finger and
I'd never experienced pain like that
alright I also went now took out and I
in that moment when oh that was painful
I was like in my mind as I was people
but I didn't feel like turning to the
other three women in the room and going
I am in some real pain no guys Arnie
yeah does anyone got any I need some gas
now for this yeah exactly and I was and
so and I thought that's not gonna fall
on ears that are thinking God poor you
so I was just like yeah cool don't worry
about the finger is fine we'll look at
that later no good and so she pushed and
they were like and by the way the
midwives were amazing these people are
incredibly well trained and one of them
just went Wow
and I was like he's definitely close and
then she said Wow
and then you just hear some crying and
we just look to each other and we look
each other dead and I'm just like oh and
then they just went cool just let the
rest of him out and then they just went
and he just shot out to the culture blow
yeah yeah they did really well actually
and then he they handed him to her and I
remember looking at her and being like
is he gonna look like that all the time
because babies when they've just been
born her a bit they're not as cute as
they look a day later oh good or even 20
minutes later because these guys I mean
imagine you have to squeeze through a
hole you know what I mean that's gonna
get gift up but like imagine you have to
squeeze your whole body through
something and then you have to look good
on the other side and yeah so he you
know I was like okay he looked a little
bit like me but it's all like someone's
it's like someone photocopied his face
mmm do you know what I mean and then put
down a second just add em self together
yeah and then we just sat there for ages
and then they put us in question yeah
what were your first words to and I said
I love you straightaway and him kissing
my head
they come out in like this waxy gunk and
sort of thing and it's nothing like the
matrix yeah nothing like the matrix I
wasn't just sort of sitting there for an
hour or whatever it was just sort of
absorbing at all I instantly oh well I
got the camera out because I didn't get
a camera out of the booth yeah and then
I'm glad I took photos instantly of Lou
being handed the trailer and I couldn't
stop like taking pictures of him and
then looking at him and taking pictures
of him and looking at him and take a
picture of him and looking at him and
then holding his hand and then they put
him to weigh him and I was like level
with his eyes and it was the first time
he properly opened his eyes and he just
looked at me my eyes went from a little
bit open to like really open and I got a
photo of it I'll show you and he was
just he was looking so hard
mmm and I was just like wow welcome to
the world fun and you just felt and then
he just felt very real effect instant
relax for those one and he was seven
pound of 107 yeah so seven pound two
ounces worth look it's not but you know
they told me they told me he was really
long yeah definitely they're like he's
tall he's a gangly [__] I like used uh
basically and he kicks and just like he
always wants to hold your hand like he
loves holding your hands and looking at
you useless apart from that what else do
they do [__] I was looking at him and I
but he walked on me a little bit the
other day like that what they do in the
first five days partly they have this
ability to like almost walk on you and
then they lose it and I put him on my
knees and you just kind of walked up my
chest
and I was just like is he meant to be
able to do this yeah and he was looking
around and everything and then he went
back to sleep that's under fall under
yeah that was it yeah he was like well
done that let's go
are you noticing his nature a little bit
so it away originally we had a name for
him which is not his name now and his
name was gonna be Xia which means fire
in think Albanian I looked him and I was
like mm-hmm that's not your name you use
don't look like as yeah I've seen them
and it definitely not he looks like a
lawrence and this is what's funny and
when you pull him out you go you
literally go well the only option here
is aren't senior it's the only option
and you haven't gone with other no god
no
lawrence a terrible name if you want a
kid to get bullies and then sure we've
gone with Rovin Robin oh a couple of
others delighted with us though what is
his nature like he's very ease calm he's
so calm but I don't know you know he's
calm
he's by the way that's not in the slang
term he's calm is complet he is calm and
he's he's always quite relaxed loves
looking at people his crying isn't
really that abrasive yet maybe that
develops as he develops his lungs I
don't know if we had a midwife over and
she was just like wow he's really calm
isn't he so everyone just says how calm
he is and how nice he looks and he's a
pretty he's a nice kid he he looks great
in red we dressed him in you know the
Liverpool kit that you bought him sorry
what yeah you know the Liverpool kit
that uncle Brian got him I was the first
person to get him some clothes just true
just true yeah yeah that is true
I know I got really every time I see him
I get was emotional and stuff the the
photo of me with him you were the first
person to get that picture because I was
like yeah it's a good picture and he is
I mean you know for a first Liverpool
game for nil against Crystal Palace it's
good he was so drunk he couldn't can we
mention a bit about your dad is that
okay
your dad's been he's been diagnosed with
cancer he's not been fairly this year
and he was one of the first people I
thought of when even when we found out
he was coming it was like you you you
know you've been through all like locked
down and covered because he's a isolate
so much more than a normal person would
and then you've got a grandson on the
way I mean even just hoping about it
a lovely guy he's off he's very likely
he's very funny very nice natured and
you sent me the picture of him talking
to him look I didn't yeah and that got
me emotional and then you run me right
after yeah you were on the train coming
back from London and you know I just had
this phone call with dad and where all
he was was smiley the whole time and he
picked up like oh my god
and it was so emotional they didn't give
your dad such a like it was just such
him I think for any person to think that
they've seen like not only their son but
then their son have a son is big mm-hmm
and he is made for this and like it's
his he's gonna be a great granddad
absolutely and it was just such a great
moment because I think he's you know
when you when you're not well what be it
whatever you start to begin to think
about Europe you know your own life and
we would I don't know it gets me kind of
just I've become confused when I talk
about it because it just feels so like
so weird right now I'm so proud of
weirdly I just looked at all the people
around me knows I'm proud of you and I'm
proud of you and you're gonna be great
and you're gonna be great and you know
what the worry is weirdly after the
birth just all went and I was like you
know you crying on the FaceTime
he cried with him five seconds of
picking up the face time and and I you
know flew and I was sitting there and
and I was just like and even flew so I
got choked up when you got choked up
yeah I know and we both sat there and I
was like I probably the worst crier and
everything so for crying in in first
class and and then flus got choked up
and then admit it was me I just I've
seen how happy you were yeah and that
was that was the thing as the last 12
months for me are new being really hard
in many different ways you know
everything that happened last summer but
also just like what a struggle it's been
with you know money and lockdown and all
that sort of [__] I'm just mental health
in general and
what you've been through with your dad
you know we you and I've been very
entered for intertwined in that time and
I think in many ways like you've carried
me for some of that carried each other
yeah and for me like this has been one
of the most unhappy years of my life yes
or so to just see that moment with you
and you flip the camera around and you
show me him and then you sort of showed
me both you guys together
I just was like [__] me like he is so
happy and I knew what you were feeling
you know I wasn't there and I wasn't
right in the room but I could feel what
you were feeling for your sudden I could
feel it and I was just like if there's
anyone who deserves that happiness on
planet earth it's you and I was just so
happy for you
that's your exact face the second that
you saw him yeah well it wasn't five
seconds like that was a lot worse and
yeah I respectfully stopped yeah I was
um I was uh that's one of the first I
mean I think it's happened before
but that's one of the first times yeah
seventy one before but in my life like a
handful of times that I've cry tears of
joy mmm like then cried cried there was
I think there's people around me going
[__] me that big guy it was really
emotional as he can I hope he's not
freaking out I was crying I was crying
because it was like I love your son yeah
and so yeah I saw that in that moment
yeah I did I just felt if forever I was
like you're my little mate now yeah I
mean and I just [__] maybe run over and
it's funny because a lot of people I
think will you know made the joke if I
you know don't be around Brian - no
because you're corrupting but actually I
said that I certa Ferrer's like when you
really get to know someone really well
then you know you're a very authentic
person on YouTube but there's much more
to you than just drinking and you know
sex and football beating people up and
yeah and a lot of people those are very
lovable or you know sort of like
caricature 9
qualities to someone or qualities you
can relate to very easily but I think
what people don't know is how nice it is
just to spend time with you in the room
well some people do do love spending
time yeah I'm sure maybe not in the edit
suite outside and I don't know in that
moment I was just so emotional I will
cry right now but I've quite a lot of
luck I just yeah I'm also very tired so
yeah it was it I was so privileged yeah
I have that second because in my head I
was like I'm just gonna hang back
because me and me and you spend so much
time together you know after your misses
I'm pretty much the guy you spent mostly
October I was like I'll I'll have my
time that this is about his mom and his
dad saying the the grandchild and her
family and I'm on my side you know she
was so choked up as well not really I
think it means so much you know some
people like their identity is that that
Parenthood thing mm-hmm
I don't actually know whether she never
considered being a you know grandparent
mhm and I think he just hit her in the
same ways it hit you the second that she
picked up the phone and you just see him
and it's real you know what also you
realize that you don't realize your
responsibility to him but you realize
your responsibility towards your whole
family at that point and all the people
who have you know been really good to
you and I don't know I just didn't you
can't you can't study for this but you
can prepare yourself for it so I'd say
if those guys out there who were
thinking you know they're growing up and
their skill is they want to develop a
skill mm-hmm take some time to develop
yourself as well cuz I know it's just
weird yeah I didn't see your mind you're
going through a lot in your absorbing so
much information right now but yeah that
one thing I got from that little moment
that we had on the first time there was
just like I don't think I've ever been
happier for another person yeah then I
was in that moment because obviously
mean you spent so many hours together
I've been through hell and back and I
was like you deserve this you'd [__]
deserve this we've had a lot over the
last 12 months
last 12 months but we've we've been
broad for years now and I remember I
just kept saying here like it's time to
be Mufasa now ya know like I should got
that photos but I took that
yeah that's the little conversation
million loan side way I was just talking
about like what it means to be your dad
and stuff for now I don't know why but I
was bring her back to me faster I was I
goes like when we were kids that was
like I mean I didn't really have a
father figure there growing up a lot
like my dad was in and out my life and I
know you listen to this and we've made
peace and it's all good but at the same
time that that that father figure he
Mufasa like the way he just sort of
takes that Simba under his wing and is
that protector that guy thinking guiding
force in his life even after he dies and
all of that sort of stuff even though
it's Disney there's a lot of truth in
that and that and you know I knew when
you became a dad you'd have that feeling
of like yeah why don't go through my
mail is yeah this yeah exactly and yeah
you um I guess you start to look at your
own dad when you become a daddy you
start to look at other people that you
want to emulate and use none
and also you start to realize like how
you can make a person be a person and
also it's something that flew and I've
really been talking about a lot was like
oh yeah he'll be like this or he'll be
like this and the thing that we both
came to the conclusion was like now he's
kind of decide what he's gonna be like
we can only really stand and we can help
him and observe him but we can't I think
a lot of people think of it as like a
Barbie doll you choose which Barbie you
get and then you play with them in that
way actually I think I think that
there's there's two sides of the
spectrum right so I think there's one
side where people think that they can
create a builder kid yeah and just make
them exactly what they want
there's the far the other far side which
is we don't really care and sadly there
are people who have kids for the
experience of having the kid and get
addicted to the pumping the babies out
but actually on hands on enough animal
and just sort of go right you go on be
here and then there's the middle which
is the ideal scenario which is what
you're aiming for yeah which is to be
there when you need me guide when you
need to be guided but also not trying to
force you to be who I wanted to be which
is why you haven't called them Laurence
after you because you wanna be is own
person yeah I'm calling premier pro I've
called in Final Cut Pro is I
I yeah exactly you know he is he's
already his own person mm-hmm and you
don't really realize that when you're
just looking at a round bump and going
you know there's something in there but
you don't know what it is yeah who it is
yet and then when you actually see their
face and you give them an identity
manual like it's a phony because
although you become a dad you're also
growing at a rapid rate now yourself
because your experience and things that
you've never been
you've never been forced to experience
before so now all of a sudden he's
growing but you're growing as well yeah
and you're having to learn as well and
adapt as well it's so funny because I
I've I mean I'm not ashamed to admit
like I my mama's counsellor right and
she said you're going to go through a
lot of change in your life and maybe you
should talk to someone about that
someone who's not
fluor me or you or someone who knows you
and can almost like bounce ideas off
with you so I started seeing a counselor
about I think about eight weeks and
maybe nine weeks ago because I thought I
really want to prepare to be a dad mmm
and it's so funny because the last
session before he was born
she just we miss a woman she's a lovely
woman called Katherine and I feel like
she'd be the ideal friend she's a great
person
but I love her and she I just we just
spent the hour just being very positive
very like affirmative not deliberately I
just walked in and was just like now I
just feel really great there's something
really great going on and I feel like I
can you know I'll do good in videos I do
get in my own life I've got all these
other things I'm thinking about like you
know with my I've seen the change in
that yeah from you I just think you're
better equipped to deal with bad
situations and what you ever have been
before because we've had so many parts I
mean unfortunately we're friendly Minges
enjoy but your mood is less affected
when [__] hits the far totally whereas
before I felt like I can you and I both
have the power that if we're in a bad
mood and we'll let it take us we can
change everyone else's mood around us as
well and we're very receptive to that as
well I think so if you're
about mood I'll probably react a certain
way him vice versa and because we're
quite you know in tune with each other
will end up affecting each other like
that
mhm and I think more and more we're
probably both learning to manage that
yeah this it is that scorpion-like
becoming a man isn't it and you know
what I realize how at every step of okay
you're a man now you know at twenty five
and every step you like you're a man now
you're a man now you're a man now and
you know then you become a dad and
you're like okay am i a man now and
you're like maybe you're a step closer
but like maybe you won't be a you know
it's funny but looking back life and
what we've experienced does know
everything that's gone before when
you're in your 20s the likelihood is is
you're not quite there yet even late
twenties most men in their late twenties
you're not quite there yet
only in my early 30s if I felt like yeah
I'm well equipped to deal with more [__]
now and I mean that's partly like you
say because of life experience as well
because I've had way more life
experience than underworld that I would
have liked you have had yeah at this age
but I I think we we all have these
experiences throughout our life where
we're starting on yeah I've got it I've
got it sussed yeah yeah oh maybe for a
minute yeah but you never do it's all
[__] but the minute you think you
have life's about to give you a good
kick in the ass just so remind you that
you don't know [__] that's a really good
point yeah yeah like you the second that
you think you understand the second it
doesn't work yeah absolutely I think
that the whole point is is to be
respectful of what could happen but also
be appreciative of what you've learned
from the past and say right while I'm
here I'm pretty happy with what I've
learned so far but I know that there's a
lot more coming and now I'm sure there's
gonna be a lot more yeah but I've really
I've just really enjoyed the whole
pregnancy and given and you know having
a child thing and you know how many days
am I now for it so 23 days in what do I
know it you know yeah absolutely and I'm
sure those people with kids talking to
go yeah good luck thing is loads of
people like yeah the first few nights
absolute hell you will happy it will be
held it was alright and actually it's
your own experience
and you know I realize is like I can
listen to I can hear all this advice we
read a whole load of stuff about how to
make a baby sleep and then the midwife
herself was just like yeah isn't really
every baby is different and I was like
great ok so what did I read all that for
I know it's worth learning yeah you took
you took it all in and out sound kidding
but what I like this is one of the
responses that you give me on a message
I was just like look if you're feeling a
little bit dead uh
you know you know I'm here and you
replied and this goes back to the story
about you reading the book UN don't
worry mate I'm Colby yeah I was like I
know exactly what you mean and you and
there's moments where you have that
great feeling and you you you know like
you probably have similar people that
you look at and go that is it just felt
you also felt it get filled with so much
purpose you get filled with so much yeah
yeah that's what I'm excited for
as your friend I'm excited to see how he
changes of you yeah cuz I know you're
gonna be there for him I already know
that that's not even a thing I'm
wondering what he's gonna do to you
because he is gonna change you 100% you
know I really don't want to be is and
please check me anyone on social media
if a I begin to post too many photos of
a child by the way there's only said
what I've happened limited by is there's
so many abstract photos of a charge you
can actually take without doing the face
in the end all right I've had the foot
the back of the head and we're done I
don't want to be one of those people who
is defined by being a parent and it's
like that becomes you know I'm a pet I'm
a parent you know if I ever start
getting like that
please check no but this is the thing
there's a big difference between being a
guy who is a new dad and is over the
moon and is happy and everyone is happy
for you then a guy who's trying to make
a career off of getting brand deals off
their children which right there's
there's damn lot out there this is not
that no one's gonna think that's that
you know it so well especially with true
news and the content movie cuz it's a
little it's not exactly mmm at home with
the the Jordi's type of know what
they're so funny I was wondering like
what's the first thing that he's going
to watch in years to come of mine and go
like wow you did never do you know what
is it that's really weird that you're
now thinking like that like one day he
could be a observing yeah he I mean I
wonder he could be impressed he could be
cringing he could be like Oh dad why did
you say that but I think if anything you
got to just live your life exactly who
to who you are and encourage him to do
the same thing and embrace that yeah and
you know I think a lot of people get but
there's a lot of things I want to be as
that and you kind of want to also take
your kid on great experiences with you
and that is that's like a high my
problem is and you know this you know
this for making right here you go this
is good imagine you know when you and I
make videos I want them to be almost
perfect Rovin those that I didn t I
think minor and I put so much thought
into it and I want it to be absolutely
everything and I want it to be almost I
don't it to be average I want it to be
you know really really perfect now put
that into a child I've had to go through
thinking about that and thinking how can
I not not [__] this up but also balance
it so that you know you don't suffocate
it but the fact that you're already
thinking about that on day three you're
gonna be okay I think so I hope so
I made um I'm making good food as well
suddenly I've just started making great
food I feel like I could cook for you
I should cook I make great steak now
well we could we could let you do a
little cooking found the pigeons in
there
alright okay weird situation so
basically there's a Soviet ventilators
no there's a there's a what's a caldron
there's a vent
going outside and some pigeons [__]
crawled up it and had two baby pigeons
ironically and it was underneath the
extractor fan so I was smelling we will
for what for a week I had to complain
about it but they got rid of them it's
stank for like a week and the pigeons
survived so good for them really exactly
you know no animals were harmed in the
making of the story but and the funny
thing is they first walked in and when
yes probably from all the stuff you've
been cooking I was like what do you
think Brian's been cooking like
yeah honestly mate but you found them in
the end the Brian sent me a photo of
these two pigeons that you then sauteed
and served out with potato doesn't want
um can we just stop what once I've got
you a present
ah four for the bore you lovely is it
suit of armor
the theme was yeah get you a son who can
do both
alright so we go one and then the other
you can tell what this is but let's just
let's let Brian sit down and then you
can explain the thinking okay um so I
thought wait wait wait
Oh what so the theme was you know he's
gonna wanna each one would want to get
up get himself out there maybe play a
little football right he's also gonna
want to go on and IO afterwards so that
is that kit to my knowledge it's the
last Cape we're in the league in and
it's the year I think you might have
been bored since at 88 yeah it's the
last year so it's it's it's what a
thoughtful present yeah so he can now
have the kit that you would have had
when you were born and you bought in the
kit that he the current one as well so
I've got him covered that is lovely this
is very thought I can totally Newcastle
is common do you know the funny thing is
no war the XO kit and on the day that I
will the XO kit the midwife point Oh
that'll be a great shirt for that and I
was that way it's like kids love black
and white
oh really yeah so so yeah I got it
really is lovely Lords of Liverpool
stuff I mean where we go through each
item think Casey shits it basically yeah
right and for when he gets bigger it's
gonna happen isn't it lovely to be
honest he's gonna grow into songs I I
got I got one one newborn m103
because I thought years gonna grow and
it might be too lucky for the other one
appreciate ya I really appreciate that
this for me or for him for him yeah babe
newborns if you don't know need hats
no that is lovely isn't it born to play
football
am I am I supposed to go through I know
you do all you on really
we're gonna sponsor this is uh I think
that's like an all over sort of thing
only for after its showers yeah although
maybe the towel down time yeah but when
he goes in the shower but when he goes
in the shower yeah he loves a good
shower we're not allowed to clean him
yet so that's a rule
oops that's lovely you've actually you
know you've actually done is I think
you've gone online and just clicked
everything almost submit yeah you got me
yeah you got me yeah that's exactly
right vote for though it's right and
then what is this so this is for he's
going out they say Gucci on the box is
we weren't Gucci so we've got to be
clear this isn't coming out the invoice
that I yes okay
getting on the box short Robin got oh
yeah baby Gucci it's spelt right as well
so you know it's from Google I'm telling
you now this is [__] genuine really
haha oh oh bright I know man you can
look like a little military Bay home is
very sweet oh you know the funny thing
is this is actually the colors of his
other nationality which the NHS listed
him as mixed other vehicle ease ease
Kasavin and these are the some of the
colors so that is lovely this is a very
thoughtful I'm not gonna put it back
because this probably worth thousands of
pounds thousands so the other estimate
yeah oh wow wow this is lovely look a
lot that is actually love it was baller
than it he's gonna look so sick in
another yeah the funny thing is I'm girl
babies are gonna be look at him like
he's fly
yeah he is fly that was one thing you do
notice when a baby comes out as you're
like look at the balls on that thing
find a way to cover them up that's I do
you go that's actually lovely isn't it
by the way I've got more stuff coming
but this was well I just went unearthing
nice items clicking and clicking thank
you so much no this is great is and then
there's this I don't know what this
that's Gucci as well so yeah it's very
fancy bright normal they luckily this
puppet show for me I didn't puppet I'll
call it it is lovely then
oh is this like you know this is like
this is like a hall you know when you're
on YouTube and you should label this
yeah yeah we will cook this up - yeah
yeah yeah absolutely yeah these are
shoes Gucci shoes as well got to have
the shoes got a funny story about that
Brian look a lot man
sure that ballin I was here thanks so
sweetness let's go Junior
violin and profilin bro that's so these
are such thoughtful lovely pile of them
he's hilarious and he's a European baby
so he's definitely gonna steal shoes
that I could never wear we're gonna see
if that was part of it you have to
understand there was a little bit of
selfishness here because I wear a double
XL Ryan men's yeah I'm like finally I
could dress how I would want a dress
just a baby sighs this is great so yeah
we love you guys so just hold the Box on
the bottom back in the box and then you
know the box is nice by the way it is
well yeah I thought this looks legit
thank you very much you genuinely spent
too much glue as a filler don't get
don't get the true but with that because
you will be robbed
well no because people don't know it's
Gucci inside they just think it's some
cheap good poet's hat that I bought I
mean that's that so that's the baby
good for them yeah if you didn't know
the thing is we only announced it like a
week ago
yes because it feels like a top and sort
of very quickly yeah as if you just and
then I was kind of like that book yeah
so now if you do fancy Lawrence you can
officially call them a DILF yeah hope
you do I've never heard that phrase so
much oh yeah thanks to all the people
who have thanks to all the people on the
day that I announced it who were in
their teens who sent me videos of them
crying or really just saying one girl
sent a video of her crying in her so
sweet but I was it was also she was just
crying I'm just so happy for you I was
like I don't know you that would terrify
me I loved it I thought was very nice I
mean anyone messaging me these days is
quite scary
yeah where you gonna put these and then
there were boys who were like yeah
whatever
workers don't dumb out what were you
telling me for I don't care and I found
it if I'm honest I
care about myself people's kids yeah you
don't hate them for that yeah I get it I
don't hate them but I'm also like you
followed me me yeah yeah exactly you
want to know what I'll do yeah yeah you
asked not me I think yeah that's a
really good point
has anyone called you daddy yeah I think
we got the tape child because there's a
girl there's a girl podcasted America
called Cole her daddy right I think I
call this episode : yeah that's good we
now call myself that
and I call my mom Nana because that was
that's the girl you inherit those names
do you know what I mean they're from the
from the previous generation and what
about your my dad's grandad bazoo yeah
he loves that and then you know we we
call those flus parents you have the
closer than words for those through yeah
which is this douche and Babbage Uche
and those are the two kind of oh yeah
it's kind of cool and then I Canton what
the great-grandma is called I mean
that's yeah I mean you know I'll be the
judge went great knock yeah exactly yeah
exactly yeah yeah Brian can turn that
can speak Albanian so amazing really
like and I have I've you know
Kristen Hennig the journalist our friend
hmm he said I just wanted to play like I
didn't know how long he's worth he sent
me a book which is English and crystal
dice so Kristen isn't it
I'm a journalist I'm gonna send you a
book titled Gucci yeah yeah who got the
better present yeah every present I get
from now on I'm gonna have to send you
one and go yeah they're not Gucci shoes
though I don't know it's gonna be like
gonna be put listen if anyone tries to
stop the mock yeah I will spend more
yeah well this is ideal because my dad
just bought me a three grand
yeah can you give me this incredible and
I'll just go spend somewhere that would
be great what would you um I mean I
guess you know when you you know when
you start thinking about your life and
you start thinking back you start going
how much can i really have laid out I
wouldn't have or I'd have been here like
you and I could never have you know
planned this mmm do you know what I mean
I started think what's my kid gonna look
that when he's 30 what is he gonna look
like when
is 40 you know I honestly I started to
think about myself dying one day really
yeah you're such a negative 12 not well
death isn't always necessary I am as
well yeah wait- in different ways and
I've been thinking about health lately a
little bit because Co video but just
because you've seen well actually you
Cove it is one of the things because
although people sort of disputed my
claim when I first started hardcore but
I think because at that time it was so
early I had caught it before it was
announced that Cove it was really even a
thing and yeah okay and then we tracked
the back and people like I was like I've
got all this and everything that they
saying and I realized that if I wasn't
such unfit fat bastard when you say I'm
fit audio vascular well right I'm very
unfit cardio I mean that's just the fact
of life I'm strong as a [__] bowl
don't ever ask me a jog down the street
and it's not it's not really my favorite
thing they do I'm fitter than most news
I'm fitter than people would think but
I'm not fit is what I want to be and the
point is I'm 22 stone and I think that
the reason I struggled so much when I
had corvid was because of my way because
most of my life I've never ever gotten
ill that often maybe once or twice once
a year maybe once every two year like it
was a very that is a very rare when I
saw you ill because I came to see it's
very rare that people even get that sort
of ill once every five years oh yeah
that was one of the most Iliff in a
mother life like top five easily
that was my brains gonna listed have a
top five homes
do you like the first time we threw up
by the way what my life hmm
no ID was horrible yeah I remember just
the terrible and ever since it sort of
really want to me I nearly died when I
was three years old and I had a illness
way I would consistently throw up and it
was something doing my white blood cells
my red blood cells rash shoes and they
thought I could die so I've been really
ill before my life and I remember that
quite vividly even I was so young you
know yeah but this was like up there you
know like I was thinking I know how
people can die from this because
let's just say for two weeks I was
coughing constantly and just the
headaches the sweats everything that
went with it but it was I coughed so
much so regularly but I for about a week
to ten days after Cove it had even gone
had such crippling pain in my ribcage
and my stomach from all of the straining
that I've been doing so I just thought
right you need to sort yourself out here
you mean actually start caring about
yourself because in your twenties you
get this mentality of you can just booze
as much as you want I'll lift some
weights and I'll be fine you're not I
mean and now I'm like probably not and
also weirdly I'm enjoying exercise as
well like I'm actually getting into it
more so I'm just like mental health wise
I've been feeling so [__] [__] about
myself and life in general and I
realized that when I do workout I do
feel a bit better not honor like it's
gonna fix everything tip but I do feel a
bit bad just even ten percent I get
something from it it doesn't pay the
[__] bills and all of that and it
doesn't cure every problem I might do
soon if you know what I mean no I mean
if you get really fit we probably get
you sponsors well you know what I mean
that's an idea yeah not not everything's
froze wads deal with me alright almost
everything but you haven't seen my child
um he is gonna be covered in Gucci this
yeah this could be the first only room
yeah genuinely I mean I acted Liverpool
FC earlier but they just haven't tweeted
back I mean they follow me as well and
outed Obama didn't even sponsor the
child so I'm just trying to make changes
in my diary it's a real problem right
now because I've tried keto and that was
was it pleasurable it was horrible but
it wasn't horrible straight away I
didn't mind it for like a week but after
a week I'm like I'm feeling like really
sluggish and slow and like part of
training especially when you are upping
your training is needing like refueled
so that was difficult so I sort of up
the carbs a little bit but I'm just I'm
working on the Thai it's it's the I'm
just more worried about getting my
training out of a sign and then I'll
sort the dialer words because I remember
you called me about a week into it and
you were saying how cool
great you a feeling yeah and I was
really happy for you once I up the
training III yeah yeah it's it's as soon
as you start training harder and more
often it's really hard to do that when
you're not having carbs I get that so
I'm gonna work on it but I know this
might be boring for you well no because
there's people out there they'll be
listening who'll be thinking I you know
I think what I'm sick of seeing is
people who were only really super fit or
do a workout every day I think most
people can't afford no I'm dying right
now I'm struggling you know like I so
last week I did boxing like two or three
times weightlifting three or four times
combo depending on what day you started
on but I felt I had a consistent
headache afterwards I probably was
dehydrated I felt like [__] like when
you first start training hard after
letting yourself go you hit a [__]
wall really quick and it's that brick
wall of like we either keep going and we
get through this and it gets easier or
it's too hard and I give up and I'm just
trying to get through this bit right now
Rocky
yeah it's you know when you haven't dead
lifted in a long time and you're [__]
ripping a heavyweight off the floor and
like keep going up now in this heat as
well as not helping I'm really
struggling but I like the heat to train
in because I love sweating when you
train see I'm a 20 to start I'll sweat
in December sure
so that's actually what you should you
should put that on a t-shirt I mean
we've got two shirts I'll straighten
December they're coming out soon look is
nice I'm strong but I'm just needing a
fitter so today I've made a purchase
this morning I've bought a trike Oh
treadmill good treadmill for the studio
I'm gonna use it in here those poor
neighbors they're gonna think someone's
constantly gonna [__] a shingle or its
Jumanji and a rhino just ended up yeah
exactly you imagine they're playing Cleo
downstairs if I've got it right there
I'm gonna [__] use it it's when
you've got to go somewhere I do
something and I just all expensive but
it's it's something where I'm actually
gonna potentially [__] change my life
did you have some life insurance policy
pay off quickly or something because
there is just there's Gucci in a box
there's a treadmill
there's one thing so your son's very
important brilliant and the fact that
you can be alive to see him is also very
internal I'm in my early thirties right
now if I don't do this now I'm probably
never going to sort my shirt we're all
in our early 30s yeah yeah yeah we've
all said that yeah but I'm just saying
it the longer you leave it the worse it
is so and mentally
I've been saw it for the last year I
need to I need to start doing something
to hurt to make it better so we're gonna
try we're gonna I might record some of
it and put out on TG - no it's gonna be
awkward when I'm like you know what I
remember a few years ago you did that
gym video the one where we can all see
your nipples and that was like four or
five years old it's a great video right
let's plan Jim thought with true Geordie
yeah and it was a really good video she
did all yourself that was when I just
met you well not so I admit I've known
you for a while but I was learning from
you I'm there did you doing great edited
myself yeah and you edit it yourself I
think you had someone just to come and
hold the camera but you sort of directed
that yourself and I remember thinking
how good it was but I'm gonna be saying
in a few years time I want to do that
but it's gonna look and sound and be
better yeah I just did another sources
yeah yeah you know I was thinking the
other day is like you know I was trying
to work out what you could say on a
podcast to young guys about having a
baby and about just you know weekend a
bit old now
you know myself past it a little I know
what you mean
I don't feel plastic but I know what you
mean yeah I definitely don't feel now
your peak I feel okay I feel like I'm in
my peak but I'm on the back end of it so
I feel like um I'm not as naive or as
ignorant or as arrogant as I used to be
because life has kicked me when I needed
it you know what's amazing is like and I
think we often talk about this aspects
it's a fun aspect and we appeal to you
know a certain kind of person we talk
about that fun dating aspect you know
you can be with different girls or you
know you can have a family we've spoken
about commitment but there's a point
that some people go on Instagram every
time I go on Instagram Instagram
suggests to me the most basic bit [__]
I've ever seen of you know like
Lele pons
stuff like yeah who's that other one who
Chuck put in a thumbnail from one
celebrity blonde girl right yeah got out
with Tommy few yeah those kind of people
right
no offense they're probably lovely no
you're not gonna learn anything yeah and
the ideas they put out there are so
basic of what a man is meant to be in a
relationship and I don't know like
that's why I read the Kobe book that
night and that's why you know when you
and I are talking about the men that we
look up to but that's the kind of man I
want to be I don't want to be I don't
know I just got this feeling sometimes
that there are and this is why this has
always been a problem in the modern
generation from since Fight Club came
out or any of these kind of things that
men don't really quite know where we fit
in right now and I've really not knowing
where I fitted in for quite a while you
know I keep telling you this I want to
keep making more videos on my own I want
to make more direct more stuff do you
know what I mean but I felt a bit
aimless and that's why I say I feel like
you've carried me for quite a while
emotionally all these kind of things you
know and that's good you want friends
who are going to help you through times
like that but I just if I can say that
to like any young guy it gets so much
better when you can get to a deeper
level of a relationship with someone and
you can really understand like that
sense of purpose in a relationship and
even if though you might not feel it now
and you might be like shut up old man or
whatever it will come one day and you're
going to be so [__] satisfied by it
and you're gonna really enjoy that and
it's so enjoyable but what do you mean
by lecture so I fully understand where
you're a lot of people you know on if
you're on Instagram where you going a
lot of mainstream I guess media
portrayals the men are all quite simple
so they're either chasing tail or they
are trying to [__] or they're trying to
trick their girlfriend into thinking
that they're not looking at the ass of
another woman or something
that's what Instagram is right now is
it's loads of like oh she's sexy and
like you should be jealous if your man
thinks of a woman in a certain way I
think a lot of a lot of these guys I've
been around these guys the lord of homes
and they're all bluffing it they're all
putting on a show
where
look why else would you [__] diet
like that like why else would you try so
hard to make yourself look a certain way
does he really care what people think
and and I get that like it's a buzz to
have people looking at you feeling great
and make you look great but like there's
a balance to be had of what what you
look like and also who you are inside
and you've got to be working on both and
I feel like a lot of people get caught
in the trap and here's what I'm
struggling with right now is balance in
life is like this there's
self-improvement of your actual who you
are inside there's financial where
you're sort of trying to manage a
business or potentially you know have
goals in life where you want to be later
on and work towards them and then
there's the physical as well and over
the last 12 months like that balance for
me went completely tits up I especially
last summer I was drinking heavy I
didn't care about myself and if anything
like even caring about myself now I'm
struggling with like it's too it's too
like give yourself a shake and go you
need to start doing something yeah and
even though I'm sitting here telling you
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that I
know I'm still if people can be like
opera he's really gotta shake I know I'm
still gonna have those moments where I'm
sitting there going there's no point
what is the point like like this person
in my life isn't like this that person
in my life isn't like that and the
frustration comes out of I'm not where I
want to be yeah and that's ultimately my
biggest challenge right you know for me
personally where I'm feeling this like
I'm not who I want to be I'm not where I
want to be I'm not satisfied I am NOT
happy in life and that is like the
honest honest truth but that's why when
you showed me you and your little boy it
was that was happiness and it was
something that haven't had in terms of
like I've had happiness along the last
12 months but but it was a real it was a
real unavoidable boom like he has some
[__] happiness you know what I mean
like can't deny that that's great and
I've definitely got people in my life
who I'm very fortunate to have and this
isn't discounting them but like
internally I can't force myself to be
happy it's something that's just
to come through time and and experience
and I'm not a patient person Lawrence as
you know so what I find is is when I'm
not reaching those goals whether it be
getting the right sponsorship for the
content getting the right content
managing what we're doing as a business
or my diet or my physical appearance or
my other interests outside of that and
having personal time arena I'm just not
doing what I want to do and I'm not I'm
not where I want to be right now and
it's it's just [__] as oft you know
what I mean yeah I understand I think
you and I have that similar feeling of
like getting that balance and also
getting also getting pleasure out of
what you're doing as well and like true
pleasure out of it you know and not just
the remote for money correct yeah
because I think that most people could
be not most but some people from the
outside might have thought of the tale
of true Geordie or did we caught the
tell the truth or do that what was that
the fall the fall right they could have
thought that that was that the title may
have misled them think that you were at
a high and all of those things were also
making you feel great but personally I
know that there was also some moments
there where you also didn't feel
fulfilled by having two great sports
cars or having you know the money to
spend or you know any of this stuff
no I've caught really is you it's not
having them yeah because actually you've
been you've been through that now it's
not you don't want a nice guy ever wants
a nice car don't be wrong but I think
what I really see in you now is you
don't you've moved on from that being
the goal and you're not chasing that
element of it anymore
yeah not that you were facile but you go
and I'm saying no I was just I was a
working-class kid who whose eyes lit up
when you seen the first car I'm human
but at the same time yeah I learned from
those mistakes and I truly truly have
learned from them I just haven't
recovered from them so go take some time
for yeah so it's like that was a year
ago now when I had to learn all that
[__] and go through all of it and it was
when you're in survival mode so it's
like when someone dies the funeral
actually is
sometimes easy sometimes because you got
something to plan for and you're so busy
you're not actually reflecting about the
death itself you're going I've got to
make sure everyone's yeah I've got to do
this I've gotta stay organized
I'm staying busy and I'm not actually
digesting what's gone on so now just to
just to explain that comparison if
someone doesn't know someone I mean it's
like at that moment when I made fall of
true joy it was six months after I'd
lost my sponsorship Minard had all that
[__] it sold your dream car
yeah I'll answer you know my life had
gone absolutely help in that six months
after I'd made follow through Jordy I
just made that fall video because I felt
like I had acknowledged how bad it was
him for me for me it just go I just need
to tell people like cuz I actually
thought if I [__] kill myself no
one's ever gonna know what the [__] was
going through my head so I just made
that make so much money from the book
that I've been offered money I just I
just literally was feeling so [__]
like down and depressed and stuff I need
it put something out there just vent hmm
and you know this is supposed to be
about you and you're new so I don't want
to bring this on it us I think it's
interesting now it were a year on it's
like after the funeral I'm able to
process what has gone on and yeah I'm
sad you know I mean it's just a very
sight it's it's sad to realize how I
feel inside right now and it's difficult
yeah and you know I have good days and
bad days it's not like I'm feeling like
it's the end of the world but I there's
just some day as it does you know me and
some just it's like anyone who has
depression the thoughts come and you
just sort of think [__] hell and then
they go and you just try and keep busy
and you just try and the one thing I've
got in my life is I've got some people
around me really care about me and I've
got a job that I do love and even though
I get frustrated with the job and I want
it to be better
I'm very lucky to have this job and I
don't want anyone thinking you know
you're in a nice flat in London and
you've got a good job you're not
grateful I'm very great
but I've also worked extremely hard to
get to this situation and I'm not wear
one of these still I want to keep trying
and keep chasing dreams and keeping
trying to make it better but that isn't
the source of you know the depression
the depression I guess this year I've
just come to a reality check of a Z as
you do when you sort of feel like you're
a man now and you know you start
reflecting on life and you go [__] me
I've been left with some scars and I'm
not just talking about the last year I'm
talking my last 10 years
like before YouTube I start you know I'm
reflecting on things happened to me when
I was younger all sorts and you just
start realizing like all right I'm here
that was really hard it's left me with
some real scars and I guess I'm just
pushing people away from me now because
I just feel like I don't know I guess
you just do that when you're feeling
down you don't you don't want to be you
need sometimes you need a bit of a long
time yeah or a bit of you need to have
your own space and also maybe you've
drawn some people towards you no sense
in me but like some people towards you
the you don't want there anymore do you
understand what I mean or not that you
don't need but that it's not the right
time for them to be around maybe that's
later maybe yes I think they say it's
lonely at the top I'm not sitting here
saying I'm at the top in terms are like
I'm not [__] jay-z but I'm very happy
with you know my career and what I've
done and but there's also just a lack of
trust in who I like I've been used by so
many people and I'm not gonna name names
of people who just taking the piss and
the passport I've been used a lot and
and it's it just makes you question what
the [__] people are around you fold you
know me and some now just like very wary
of who I interact with which can be
quite inhibiting because you end up not
sometimes you might end up on not having
opportunity I'm turning into one of
those people who's like doesn't want to
be around other people that's not that
is never who I was I was always the life
and soul of the party and now I'm a more
much much more like leave me
feelings like that come and go as well
though don't they like that yeah that
can feel like especially with that
feeling that can feel really permanent
in that moment and if [__] does but
it isn't your mind convincing you this
is it
[__] it yeah exactly and you in many
ways it makes you grit your teeth it
makes you work really hard in that time
and then you come out the other side of
it but I get what you're saying that can
backfill incredibly lonely but also I'm
not the type of person as you know it to
bury like to pour all my problems onto
one other person and be like yeah like
I'm talking very figuratively I'm not
being very specific but I don't like to
sit down with one person and just go so
he has everything that's wrong with me
and yeah you know it's it's not my style
either so I don't know I like you say I
understand our depression where it gets
really bad it gets a bit badass you know
sometimes you could not have it for ages
and feel like you've got it all under
control and it's gone and then it can
come right back with you and when you
least expect it so it's just it's easy
saying that it's like just living with
it can be a challenge in general I mean
it also seems like you come to a lot of
realizations in your life that maybe you
are more emotionally equipped to deal
with the stuff you've been through in
your twenties then you were at that time
and the psyche ago maybe some of that
stuff you hadn't fully processed and now
you're old enough as a man or two it's
kind of coming back and you are
processing yeah yeah and no it's all
coming back now but that's not a bad
thing but it is a hard path to walk yeah
I think everyone sort of thinks I've
been through that done right and we both
know it's like I said though I spend so
much of my life trying to survive the
[__] that I'd went through mmm like what
happened in the last 12 months that I
got to a point where once I've gone
through it all and I know [__] hell I
have survived I've stopped drinking and
now I'm I'm alright
maybe I'm just gonna be fine now and
that's when I started reflecting on it
and realizing like God the world's a
[__] place like and people have been
[__] to me hmm
and now I just don't like people anymore
like I don't trust people anymore like
that you know what I mean like that
you know you understand why people say
no new friends at that point yeah it
gets like that you know what I'm saying
so we just with the unfriend stuck with
me now yeah but luckily you've just had
a new one suckin adopt him into the
circle of trust you know the funny thing
is I was actually thinking about that I
was talking to my dad on the phone about
it because he's got a lot of friends
sort of you know he's got a lot of
friends that I love seeing because
they're such great like cool guys and
there was a story I'll tell you this
story from I was a kid right my dad and
his friend went golfing one of my dad's
friends is a very rich man and he's
owned a lot of businesses in fact quite
a few of my dad's friends are very rich
men not the good she shows the other no
although actually one of them does Wagyu
issues and I was thinking like you know
what's my son gonna have around him and
there was always this one friend there
was a couple of friends that I got
really excited but this is one friend
who had like a bit of a glint in his eye
and is clearly quite a character and I
would always get a bit excited when he
visit my dad because I was a bit like
something cool is gonna happen today
when this friend visits and this guy had
a Porsche and it was the first sort of
nice car that I'd ever been in I my dad
herb Hojo and my dad's mate said let's
drive to the Gulf I was gonna caddy for
them and they were gonna and I was just
I was happy just walk around with my dad
and be with him you know how you are as
a son but usually love being with your
dad even if they're not good dad you'll
still love being with your dad at some
point and he went but Lawrence comes
with me in the Porsche and I was like
yes yes I want to come with me sorry dad
so yeah sorry see you later
and I remember we got in the Porsche and
he went what's your favorite song and I
was like the boys are back in town
and he he put the CD in of that and just
turned it right up and then I think we
arrived at the Gulf about five minutes
before my dad did but we had the fastest
journey I've ever had in my life and I
was like yeah that's what Brian's gonna
be like for my son like you're just
gonna be the guy that turns up and is
like what crazy [__] should we do today
then you
yeah definitely give him a few words of
wisdom when you're yeah so so just so
you know though he also gave me pokemon
yellow on the Gameboy so that is a very
high level that this guy reached its
gonna mean at least a PS fives gonna
have this kid yeah and when I say a PS 5
it's sort of a family pretty sure he's
gonna be too young for ps5 no I mean you
can't appreciate color enough Brian and
what's going on in that world is gonna
teach him a lot you saw yeah exactly
yeah I mean he was loving that Liverpool
so just to be clear
Lauren sends me a video of the first
goal he seen Liverpool's score after his
son was born was Trent Alexander Arnold
free-kick what a first score but great
free kicks great way to start yeah and
he just pans over it was and he goes the
crowd goes wild and literally he's not
intense I was like he's just sleeping
and then lord sree started I was like so
this is Lawrence's a Dada
plenty more like that where that comes
from isn't it crazy though he arrives
the the final literally the last time
live won the title that was my year and
the date the year that he arrives few
people are message me and gone is there
any chance you could crack a few more
babies out during the year than clop era
it's a possibility
so we're going for the trouble going for
the travel yep yeah if I have two more
kids will win a Champions League and the
FA Cup in the same year now that's
special me and I remember throughout the
season I was saying to you your son's
gonna be born in the championship
winning season in my Malin I kept saying
it you know like well maybe I'll like
it's up there yeah is real yeah it's a
mantle isn't it and it's a memory you'll
never forget me yeah it's been a good
chart that day
thanks everyone who's been with us on
this journey is lucky I made it to this
point where those nine others that the
orgies are I think they're still here
with us they're still here through the
bombshell our fro ups and down through
adults and yeah it's a really emotional
one for me this one I think for both big
home it's a strange day to even see each
other today isn't it feels a bit
different yeah hopefully everyone's
enjoyed if you have obviously hit the
like button
we'll be back to in the kickoff all of
July we got a live stream of gaming now
on TG 2 if you didn't know that I'm
doing some gaming like those games yeah
I've got loads of games I'd like you to
take me through a couple of those I
think I can join you for some more live
streams I know people want to see you on
your own but I need all the help I can
get me now as you seen yeah so on Teja -
we're doing gaming live streams with
more clips and yeah hopefully you
subscribe to the kickoff RTG - if you
haven't already hit the subscribe button
for this channel I love you
Navin T thanks for watching we'll see as
we are